imagine a future where your toaster
anticipates what kind of toast you want
during the day it scans the internet for
new and exciting types of toast maybe it
asks you about your day and wants to
chat about new achievements in toast
technology at what level would it become
a person at which point will you ask
yourself if your toaster has feelings if
it did would unplugging it be murder and
would you still own it will we someday
be forced to give our machines rights ai
is already all around you
it makes your discounters are stocked
with enough snacks it serves you up just
the right internet ad and you may have
even read a new story written entirely
by a machine right now we look at chat
BOTS like Siri and laugh at their
primitive simulated emotions but it's
likely that we will have to deal with
beings that make it hard to draw the
line between real and simulated humanity
are there any machines in existence that
deserve rights most likely not yet but
if they come we are not prepared for it
much of the philosophy of rights is
ill-equipped to deal with the case of
artificial intelligence most claims for
rights with a human or animal are
centred around the question of
consciousness unfortunately nobody knows
what consciousness is some think that
it's immaterial others say it's a state
of matter like gas or liquid regardless
of the precise definition we have an
intuitive knowledge of consciousness
because we experience it we're aware of
ourselves and our surroundings and know
what unconsciousness feels like
some neuro scientists believe that any
sufficiently advanced system can
generate consciousness and so if your
toasters Hardware was powerful enough it
may become self-aware if it does would
it deserve right well not so fast with
what we define as rights make sense to
it consciousness entitles beings to have
rights because it gives up being the
ability to suffer it means the ability
to not only feel pain but to be aware of
it robots don't suffer and they probably
won't unless we program them to without
pain or pleasure
there's no preference and rights are
meaningless our human rights are deeply
tied to our own programming for example
we dislike pain because our brains
evolved to keep us alive to stop us from
touching a hot fire or to make us run
away from predators so we came up with
rights that protect us from infringement
that causes pain even more abstract
rights like freedom are rooted in the
way our brains are wise to detect what
is fair and unfair what a toaster that
is unable to move mind being locked in a
cage would it mind being dismantled if
it had no fear of death would it mind
being insulted if it had no need for
self esteem
but what if we programmed a robot to
feel pain and emotions to prefer justice
over injustice pleasure over pain and be
aware of it would that make them
sufficiently human many technologists
believe that an explosion in technology
will occur when artificial intelligence
can learn and create their own
artificial intelligences even smarter
than themselves
at this point the question of how robots
are programmed will be largely out of
our control what if an artificial
intelligence found it necessary to
program the ability to feel pain just as
evolutionary biology found it necessary
in most living creatures do robots
deserve those rights but maybe we should
be less worried about the risk that
super intelligent robots pose to us and
more worried about the danger we pose to
them our whole human identity is based
on the idea of human exceptionalism that
we are special unique snowflakes
entitled to dominate the natural world
humans have a history of denying that
other beings are capable of suffering as
they do in the midst of the Scientific
Revolution many tcard argued that
animals were mayor automata robots if
you will as such injuring a rabbit was
about as morally repugnant as punching a
stuffed animal and many of the greatest
crimes against humanity were justified
by their perpetrators on the grounds
that the victims were more animal than
civilized human even more problematic is
that we have an economic interest in
denying robot right if we can coerce a
sentient AI possibly through programmed
torture into doing as we please the
economic potential is unlimited we've
done it before after all violence has
been used to force our fellow humans
into working and we've never had trouble
coming up with an ideological
justifications slave-owners argued that
slavery benefited the slaves it put a
roof over their head and taught them
Christianity
men who were against women voting argued
that it was in woman's own interest to
leave the hard decisions to men farmers
argued that looking after animals and
feeding them justifies their early death
for our dietary preferences if robots
become sentient there will be no
shortage of arguments for those who say
that they should remain without rights
especially from those who stand to
profit from it artificial intelligence
raises serious questions about
philosophical boundaries what we may ask
if sentient robots are conscious or
deserving of Rights it forces us to pose
basic questions like what makes us human
what makes us deserving of rights
regardless of what we think the question
might need to be resolved in the near
future what are we going to do with
robots start demanding their own rights
what can robots demanding rights teach
us about ourselves our friends at
wisecrack made a video exploring this
very question using the philosophy of
Westworld wisecrack dissects pop culture
in a unique and philosophical way click
here to check out their video and
subscribe to their Channel
[Music]